all right nothing subtle about the
situation in Dallas they got a couple of
guys there trying to get signed dak
Cooper dak dak Prescott in Amari Cooper
dak Cooper that's the way they should
come together and handle this thing but
dak Prescott Amari Cooper there was a
report earlier this week that more
progress has been made with dak Prescott
the Cowboys quarterback then Amari
Cooper the receiver that was acquired
last year for a first-round draft pick
now someone suggested to me yesterday
and this is one of those where you'll
wish you'd thought of it on your own
because this situation is not
unprecedented
now it is unprecedented the two players
would come together the way that I'm
suggesting Prescott and Cooper should
which is to say to the Cowboys plainly
and simply hey look we both are due to
be free agents next year we both are
coming together to refused to sign a new
contract and we're going to force you to
make a choice between which one of us
you're gonna apply the franchise tag to
the other guy is gonna be a free agent
and you know the guy who gets a
franchise tag can then negotiate his
long term deal from under the franchise
tag that's no problem you still get your
long term deal but by refusing to do a
deal now because all it takes is one guy
to do the deal now and the team has the
franchise tag leverage over him going
forward if they come together and say we
refuse the players turn the tables on
the team in a legitimate way they
complain about the franchise tag all the
time players and agents do this is a way
for players and agents to come together
and turn the tables and it's something
that Prescott and Cooper and their
agents need to seriously consider
definitely I mean again these are 32
billionaires who will use any avenue
possible to you know increase their
business leverage and we're seeing more
and more every year and you fight for it
you talk about it a lot and I know we
both do but pliers are becoming smarter
and starting to use their leverage in
more significant ways as well so I could
certainly see this happening look I can
just if I had to put myself in dak
Prescott shoes and I got a maybe a below
the market offer an unfair offer for
what I thought I should be paying as a
starting quarterback of the Dallas
Cowboys and not a lot of progress is
going on with Amari Cooper and I have a
good relationship with Amari Cooper I'm
gonna have some conversations about you
know the business dealings what are they
saying to you what are they offering you
where you
and yes maybe you do come together and
start to go okay well maybe let's game
plan this out a little bit so they can't
find a way to screw us both over now I
have a very hard time believing that's
gonna happen I mean I'm not shocked that
dak Prescott they're further along with
his contract than Amari Cooper they
should be
I mean dak Prescott they drafted him and
all he's done has been a stand-up
starting quarterback on and off the
field and he's led them to the playoffs
two into three years so there's a lot of
positives there and he should be the guy
but but I just think at some point here
soon we're gonna hear an offer made to
dak Prescott that I just would be
shocked that he would be able to turn it
down are you gonna be able to turn down
you know twenty eight thirty million
dollars a year with 90 million
guaranteed even though you might not
like it totally can you turn that down I
would say no well and that's the
distinction you can say what you want
all day long but then at some point they
put an offer on the table and you have
to stare at and you have to consider the
consequences of not taking it dak
Prescott do to make only two million
this year if you offer him a deal that
pays him 28 million a year even if he
wants 31 do you say no to 28 and roll
the dice on the possibility of a serious
neck injury a serious leg injury I mean
even though quarterbacks are staying
healthier and healthier and last year I
think it was 16 teams half the league
had the same starting quarterback all
year long and the rules continuously
have been massaged in favor of
protecting quarterbacks you still can
have that Alex Smith injury and you
never know when that's gonna happen and
it's it's hard to say no to that
security especially when being the
quarterback of the Dallas Cowboys has so
many other collateral benefits Yamma
endorsement standpoint
you'll waltz right into a broadcast
booth when your career is over Tony Romo
was on the brink of getting 10 million
dollars a year from CBS so that that and
I wouldn't be surprised if the Cowboys
don't bring Romo in at some point to
talk to to Prescott you know under the
guise of hey here's how I handled my
business and maybe this will help you
and I look I don't know that it comes to
that but I can see the cowboy was doing
everything they can to get Prescott to
take whatever they want him to take but
that's why I think it's fair for
Prescott and Cooper yeah
put their heads together to get the
agents to compare notes and come up with
a strategy that helps both of them and
both of them saying we refuse to sign a
contract until after the season until
after the franchise tag window closed
helps both of them because even if
Prescott doesn't do a deal now again
he's got to carry the injury risk this
year but franchise tag is gonna be more
than 25 million next year he gets a 20%
raise if he gets tagged a second time
he's gonna make a lot of money yeah 2020
and 2021 the challenge is saying no to
whatever the best offer is going into
this season and running the risk of
getting the kind of injury that keeps
you from ever getting the big payday
that's the downside for both guys yeah
if they say no to a long-term offer now
yes it is and then to me or at least in
my advice or opinion I would say don't
turn down those long-term offers
especially I'm talking about a guy like
dak Prescott who you know again is known
for you know his abilities in the NFL as
a starting quarterback to play the
position a little bit more physically
than maybe we see other quarterbacks do
it I mean we saw some big contact run
running plays by dak Prescott in the
divisional playoff game against the Rams
had a running touchdown on from like the
2 or 3 yard line I believe it was on a
fourth down where he put his head down
and and had some big-time contact with
two Rams defenders so I would always say
hey err on the safe side don't roll the
dice too much you know me personally I
can speak to that because it can come
back to bite you in the butt I thought I
was an indestructible oh I'll play this
you know I'll play my tender out and
I'll sign a new contract the next year
because I'm big and strong and you know
Jon Gruden used to call me big soldier
cuz I was fearless in the pocket and all
those things well damn I might have been
fearless but you know Kris Jenkins and
Thomas Davis messed me up and I never
saw that money so you know that's the
things you do have to worry about other
thing Mike are you surprised deke Elliot
hasn't jumped into the conversation
about wanting new money yet either I
mean yes okay I just wanted to make sure
like cuz we talked about it a few weeks
ago to where we said Zeek Elliot should
be asking for more money I mean you led
football and rushing to into the last
three years and they're working you at a
pace that is greater than any other
running back in football I'm actually
shocked that Zeek is being so quiet
about this in their camp Stephen Jones
on this
Grahame last week said that zeke is the
straw that stirs the drink well at some
point you got to refill the glass Elliot
look the risk is now Jones made it clear
that they will get Elliott signed but we
could probably go back through old
quotes and there was probably a member
of the Jones family that suggested they
were gonna get DeMarco Murray signed and
they never did I'm concerned if I'm a
Zico Elliot of getting chewed up and
spit out yeah five years of a rookie
contract one year of franchise tag and
then they say thanks but we're gonna
move in a different direction that's the
concern I would have if I was a zq Ali
and that's why I'd be standing up now
saying I want mine give me mine now and
really if Prescott and Cooper were to
pull off this strategy that I'm
suggesting where you do one guy gets
franchise tagged one guy hits the market
whoever gets franchise tagged they
should do the same deal with Ezekiel
that's where I was going with it right
he should be the next guy involved in
this you're right I mean that that makes
too much sense but you know back to the
Ezekiel Elliott point yeah it scares me
and I really want to say that to Ezekiel
yeah man come on you need to ask for
more money right now you got to get your
long-term security you know I would also
say to the Cowboys I think if they
offered him some type of deal like Todd
Gurley God he'd probably take it right
now and run to the bank and that
wouldn't be so bad for the Dallas
Cowboys
but man Zeke Elliott is the type of
running back that does scare me as far
as longevity of his career he is the
lifeline of that offense he has leverage
here because the team's really built
around the run game and he is far and
away the best running back on their
roster they're a different team when he
doesn't play I mean we saw he got
suspended for six weeks and had to deal
with that that in 2018 or 17 and the
Cowboys were never the same because he
was their best player on their team but
he he plays car crash running back
football and I worry that in year five
and year 6 and year 7 of Ezekiel
Elliott's career that he is gonna take
too many big hits and never be the same
guy that we're seeing right now Chris
the most important important two words
you said there were Todd Gurley that's
why the Cowboys want to wait I believe
because the Rams paid Todd Gurley all
that money going into year four and what
happened the knee condition it actually
started
one after the win over the Raiders his
knee was bothering him the swelling went
away quickly but it was later in the
year it knocked him out of multiple
regular-season games and then he wasn't
the same guy down the stretch he had the
good game against the Cowboys but the
NFC championship game is a
disappointment Super Bowl was a
disappointment and now the Rams are
locked up with all that money for for
injury guaranteed for injury I think if
you're the Cowboys let's get through
this fourth year before we make the
long-term commitment with Ezekiel eight
because with running back you never know
which hit is going to be the one that
permanently changes the guy's career and
and that's a fair concern and and that
that supports the idea of using two or
three running backs all the time of
never giving big money to any running
back unless you think you have Jim Brown
or Barry Sanders in his prime and also
wait as long as you can until you make
that that that big payday because the
Rams surely regret giving Todd Gurley
the contract they did and there's no way
they'd give him that contract now based
upon what happened last season no but
but I'll just say there's the difference
here just at least with these two
players is Todd Gurley got drafted
coming off an ACL tear I mean he didn't
get to play his last year in college
football at least the full season
because of that ACL tear so there was
knee issues to begin with Ezekiel
Elliott can argue I've never banged up I
take I take 30 car crashes a week and I
come back to the next week and I'm ready
to do it again so he can at least use
that to his argument but I hear you I
mean your points are valid I mean
certainly I'd be worried about that too
if I was the Jones family it does it
takes one play and a running back and to
his career and the way he plays can be
drastically changed in a hurry
well the Cowboys have issues that they
will resolve at some point and I have a
feeling they'll figure out a way to keep
everybody together and keep pushing
toward that Super Bowl championship that
Jerry covets so much
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports